we begin with breaking news out of Iran
where officials are saying that at least
73 people have been killed in two
explosions during a ceremony honoring
the slain Iranian General kasum
salamani the blast struck as hundreds of
people gathered near his grave site in
the Central City of comman another 170
people were injured State media qu are
quoting an Iranian off official who's
described it as a terrorist attack
Tuesday marks four years since the top
General was killed by a us drone attack
near the airport in
Baghdad let's speak to Mustafa koshish
he's an Iranian political analyst who
has worked for the Iranian foreign
Ministries international relations
faculty and he joins us from tan Mustafa
first of all can you fill us in on what
happened as far as you're
aware hello and thanks for having me
well uh a couple of bombs uh uh
detonated actually um a few hundred
yards away from the symmetry of uh the
city of Kerman just a few hundred yards
away from the burial place of uh Iran's
mared General solmani and uh on the path
people were moving to join the
procession the
anniversary uh there are people there um
there are stations there by the people
uh who distribute foods and drink and
everything and suddenly the first bomb
which was more powerful
apparently um detonated and a number of
people were marted as the rescue squad
were rushing to the scenes um uh the
second bomb also exploded killing more
civilians who have rushed to the scene
to help the wounded and the dead and uh
it has so far mar is over 73 people
almost all of them civilians including
at least seven eight children and also
171 have been wounded so far the numbers
could be rising uh but of course there
have been as far as we know and as far
as it's been announced by the officials
uh we have not heard of any official or
military uh casualties because the
police the law enforcement and others
they were stationed at the cemetery at
the gates of the cemetery a few hundred
yards away and now the procession the
anniversary uh moved ahead uh right away
and now as live cameras are showing from
uh the Symmetry uh the the anniversary
continues very peacefully by the MERS
just tell us how important this ceremony
is this commemoration of the death of
salamani it's highly important because
uh you know when U General Lieutenant
General sumani was bed uh he was given
processions in different cities in Iran
and Iraq a number of 25 million people
took part in that procession the largest
ever we heard on Earth in the history
and people love him adore him admire him
uh they there are pilgrims who go to his
burial place uh every day so it's highly
important that makes the event more
Paramount and more important and more
vital because definitely this has been a
major breach uh and a terrorist attack
on Iranian civilians which will not uh
you know uh be un respon without the
response uh definitely uh Iran is very
much sensitive to those that harm its
security and especially U killing
Iranian citizens has always been a red
line so considering the events in the
last 10 days uh it seems that we should
be waiting for um teran's response to
those in charge of these attacks uh
we've just getting um an update that now
the death toll has risen to 81 that's 81
people killed in these two explosions
you say with some certainty that these
were bombs that they were remotely
detonated indeed in Iranian media we're
seeing reports that they were also
remote
detonated but do we know with any
certainty that fact or do is that still
speculation at this stage and also who
do we think might be behind
it well um um official reports have been
silent about this investigations are
under the way by the Iranian
intelligence Ministry to clarify if uh
there has been any suicide bombing or
both have been removed bombs but
definitely at least one of them has been
bomb attacks but some of uh uh you know
friends on the scene uh have been saying
that they've seen two uh uh bags and
there that and they are sure that the
two have been uh bombs remotely exploded
but there is no official report about
that also about those culprits behind
the crime the terrorists uh there has
been no official report Iran's interior
minister is going to speak to the
Iranian media in about a few minutes now
but my personal Gathering is that that
this has been Israel this has been mad
definitely for me is completely clear
considering the events in the last 10
days the terrorist attacks they started
in Damascus then they in Beirut now in
Iran they have failed apparently to find
the dignitaries officials and militaries
that's uh their uh protocol that's their
program and plan always that whenever
they fail to do so they go for the
public in order to create a tragedy
apparently uh the to me it's completely
clear that Netanyahu has failed in his
war on Gaza and he is empty-handed in
front of the Zionist inside the occupied
territories his government is very much
fragile and might collapse soon and God
knows that his political career will end
up in behind jails soon so he after this
failure in Gaza uh he's trying to uh uh
you know show that he has he has earned
something at least uh uh he wants to say
probably to the Israelis that uh he has
done some reprisal attacks in Beirut in
Damascus and in tan um but at the same
time the Strategic Target seems to me to
be escalating the tensions in the region
that has been what Netanyahu and his
army and mad they've been doing um
moving Heaven and Earth in order to
escalate the tensions uh since a few
weeks ago uh because they want to bring
the United States and their European
NATO backers into this conflict in order
to escape this defeat and failure in
Gaza and in order to continue this war
so so far teran's shown reservations and
and self-restraint but I do believe that
after the mm of razi General razi last
week as well as uh today event which was
a tragedy and killing Iranian citizens
um a mass murder um uh there will be a
response definitely and there will be
dire costs for the Israelis okay Mustafa
Kish thanks very much for taking the
time to speak to us there uh from tan